this is a temper in a simple rectangle
segmented into ten equal sized boxes in
two rows of five a ten frame is a tool
that is designed to encourage
kindergarten and first-grade students to
understand numbers in relation to the
number ten and organize physical items
they will be counting ten is important
because it is the base of our number
system we only write with a numeral x'
zero through nine so to indicate the
next larger counting number beyond nine
we must write our numerals in a new
place known as the tens place when we
have a group of ten ones or in other
words when we fill our 10 frame we
recognize that we have enough to bundle
the group into a new value indicated by
placing a numeral one in the position to
the left of the ones place known as the
tens place this is the beginning phase
for understanding place value to learn
more about the development of place
value in Singapore math please watch the
short video on the place value chart in
the early stages of the development of
numbers encourage your child to build a
given quantity or show you a specific
number of items from zero to ten such as
show me for the child would then place
the counters on the tenth frame one two
three four there we go
in this example I am using the two
colored counters which are red on one
side and yellow on the other but you
could use small and large buttons or
different types of dry beans really
whatever you have lying around the house
also drawing your own 10 frame to use
with your child is really quick and easy
to do later you will develop the
concepts of addition and subtraction by
asking him to add or subtract some
amount you could say something like now
add three more and tell me how many
there are they would then place three
more counters on the
frame and let you know that there are
now seven counters or buttons or beans
as you work with your child is important
to consistently refer to the number ten
understanding numbers and each numbers
relationship to ten help students
develop strategies used in mental math
so questions such as how many more do we
need to make ten is really valuable to
better understand how this helps with
mental math please take a moment to
watch the video about number bonds
another great way to use the ten frame
is to ask the question how many
different ways can you make a number
such as seven doing this can help
develop a child's sense of what each
number can be made of this is also a
helpful way to start developing addition
and subtraction math facts through ten
and it leads well into the already
referenced number bonds which again I
discuss in another video but simply put
it is a picture representation of how to
break apart numbers into smaller
component parts thanks for watching and
please check out the other videos
available online